there are a lot of different examples
that we've been able to leverage on this
incredible tech stack that Facebook and
messenger and whatsapp and Instagram
these are big big rich services with
hundreds of millions of people on each
and there's a lot of code there and
being able to go and see this kind of
menu of code stack of features and being
able to pick and choose and put that
together for oculus has enabled us to
move a lot faster with a much better
platform so how has the marriage with
Facebook been so far so it's been great
we've gone from shaking hands with Mark
at 60 people too many many hundreds of
people now and in two years we've
relocated onto Facebook campus so the
food's improved we get free ice cream it
really has been great so I mean you guys
are under a tremendous amount of
pressure I mean expectations are high I
mean how does that that which can I
think strain any marriage but how are
you dealing with that well when we got
acquired it definitely woke everyone up
and I was talking about that before that
was something we knew was going to
happen it was a moment where Mark got up
and said VR is the next platform and
definitely suddenly the world took
notice more than when we had been
pioneering it just as a start-up and so
there are a lot of people in the VR
space but this is what we need it this
is what VR needed and it really is the
best thing for VR because ultimately
there has to be lots to do and there has
to be a huge ecosystem of content and
the more people that are out there
investing in VR the more likely that's
to be how involved is Mark personally I
think he's quite involved like how often
to you guys given how exciting the space
is and how many breakthroughs are going
to come from oculus and in the VR space
mark has really dialed in to what we're
doing I think he posts whenever a
president visits he takes him right into
oculus toy box and shows them the latest
demos and it really is the next big
platform and so for Mark who i think has
this pretty successful mature platform
out there on the mobile side with
facebook being able to look at what's
next is really exciting and engaging so
he spends a lot of time when you
think back if you hadn't told to
Facebook would today be happening what
the riff to be really saying now so I
think we would still be releasing now
but it wouldn't be at the quality level
it is and it wouldn't have this kind of
content lineup and really today game
days is all about games and there's 30
games over 30 games at launch there's
going to be I think we're showing 41
games here today there's going to be
dozens more coming right in the first
few months that kind of momentum and
that kind of breadth of content just
wouldn't be there if we didn't have
partnered up with facebook and so we're
in a much much better place because of
the partnership do you ever think what
if we'd stayed an independent and how
different things would be well a lot of
things cross your mind and I think there
are a lot of moments where we actually
look at each other as a team and say I'm
so glad we're here at Facebook really it
happens time and time again a lot of the
industry is moving quickly there are a
lot of competitors getting into space
there is the need for a lot of content
and the ecosystem needs a lot of support
to build a hardware device takes a lot
of people and all of these things add up
to us being really happy that we're at
Facebook and we have this kind of
support do you think the competition
move more quickly whether it's Sony or
HTC or Samsung because of the Facebook
acquisition like did you did you get
free kick everyone else into high gear
yeah absolutely i think so i think that
it woke a lot of people up when the CEO
of a multi-billion dollar company gets
up and says that vr is the next
computing platform one of the you know
biggest most successful tech companies
out there says this is it vr is the next
platform that gets everybody on board
that gets a lot of people inspired to go
out there